giant multinational corporations don't
generally have the best of reputations
and i want to stress that this is not an
advert for mcdonald's i approach them
about filming this because almost
everyone who watches this video will
have eaten at mcdonald's at some point
in their lives i'm sure the few of you
who have always turned down the
opportunity we'll be very vocal about in
the comments but for the majority of
people who have eaten at the golden
arches well the experience will be
roughly the same wherever you are that's
the point of fast food change
everything's standardized you get the
same experience the same food no matter
where you are
right
well when i heard that the world's only
float through mcdonald's was on a little
canal on the elbe river in germany
i thought that was probably worth a
visit
now just to manage your expectations uh
this is not a mcdonald's with a moat
around it where there's a queue of
kayaks lining up for each window and
turn uh that would be better but uh
while there was an actual microphone
speaker here once a few years ago these
days the 21st century has arrived you
have to order on the smartphone app we
have the mcboat since 2015.
in the winter we may close yes
but uh in summer and in spring we have
24 7. people are so happy to see this
because they read this i saw this in
instagram and they come especially for
this we can see your order on the screen
and we make your food ready
and one person goes and bring the bag
out and wish them a good enjoy your meal
and a happy good day one of the things
i've learned over the years i've been
making videos is that people like a
combination of familiarity and novelty
if everything changes people don't like
it and they move to other things but if
nothing changes people get bored and
they move to other things and in the
same way i think it's fascinating to
find something that's very close to what
you already know but that changes it in
one or two interesting ways
when something like mcdonald's
has a reputation for being
controlled and standardized and you know
exactly what to expect well seeing small
reinventions of that formula can be
fascinating plus it gives them some
publicity
oh and one more thing i didn't mention
exactly where in germany we are because
it is quite apt that the world's only
float through mcdonald's is in hamburg
you